the relationship between art and
religion is almost without exception
very strong and significant almost
basically any religion that you can
possibly think of has some sort of
artistic expression associated with it
whether that be the architecture of
religious buildings or idols and statues
poetry or other forms of literature and
and so on
another prominent of these artistic
expressions and one of my main fields of
interest is of course also music music
is called a universal language one that
has been used by basically every culture
in some form everything from rock
concerts to military parades or
religious ceremonies music is everywhere
in the world in different cultures and
the Muslim world is no exception
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
today there's a lot of different music
coming out of the so called Islamic
world a lot of us have heard the songs
by Uncle Tom
or Pharaohs or chant harlot and there
are love songs and pop songs there is
religious nasheed music about the
Prophet Muhammad there is political
hip-hop and even metal music all of this
coming out of the Islamic world or the
Middle East and this diversity has
existed historically as well music was
very much present in the early Muslim
community as I stated in previous videos
we know fairly little about the first
hundred years or so after the Prophet
Muhammad's death but there seems from
the sources we have the certainly seems
to have been many musicians in Mecca and
Medina many of these were women who
would sing and play instruments at
different kinds of gatherings music was
also often used to accompany poetry
which was very strong of a tradition in
the region since long before the Prophet
Muhammad the traditional music was
strongly connected to poetry in
pre-islamic Arabia and this also
continued in later periods instruments
like the frame drum or flutes and
possibly also woods or lutes were
probably used to accompany singing of
poems of different sorts the word used
to refer to music at this time was Elena
which literally means singing and so
this shows you that music was primarily
a vocal art used to sing certain poems
and was sometimes accompanied by
instruments but not always according to
later sources the first famous male
musician from this region is a man by
the name of two ways who would sing an
accompany himself by playing the Duff
drum he lived in Medina shortly after
the two prophets death there's also an
individual by the name Eibon Messiah who
was an early composer and music theorist
expanding the melodic and mortal
horizons of the music of the Arabs at
the time as the Muslim Empire expanded
under the Umayyad caliphs a lot of
influence was taken from neighboring
regions and of course local traditions
from the lands that
Concord so Mesopotamia and Persia and
North Africa and so on
many of the Umayyad Caleb's appeared to
have been great lovers of music and
they're developed a kind of tradition of
court music that would continue as these
centuries went by in some of the early
arts like in the Umayyad desert castles
there are depictions of musicians like
these frescoes from Casa
Amara in modern-day Jordan they depict
musicians and apparently a bear playing
the earth as well as other very
fascinating scenes it may be surprising
to some of you to see depictions of
human beings and animals in Islamic art
but we must remember to avoid sort of
projecting later opinions backward in
history these images are very early on
during the Mayan times and only a few
decades after the Prophet Muhammad's
death and the debate on depictions of
humans probably wasn't decided not all
at this point it's never really been
decided but especially not this early on
after the Ambassador evolution in 750
and during their Caliphate which is
often referred to as the Golden Age
music really developed into a
sophisticated art form musicians from
Persia and other regions brought with
them of course local musical traditions
that merged with the Arabic tradition to
create or give it a new life and
creating new sophisticated forms of
music and of course there were also
influences taken from the Greek
tradition Greek philosophy and many
other ideas that were being syncretized
and and developed in the Abbasid
Caliphate in Baghdad and in other
regions music during this period
especially theoretically but also
practically became an important part of
higher education in certain strata of
society
it was almost obligatory for the learned
elite to learn music the caleb's
gathered around them very talented
musicians who would frequent the courts
and some of the most famous of these
early musicians include a man by the
name of yuk el mao silly and his father
Ibrahim and mostly they were both of
Persian origin and served in the court
of the very famous caliph harun
al-rashid and thus they lived some time
around the late 8th to early 9th
centuries it is said that a subtle mouse
earring brought over 40 treatises about
music and had a vast knowledge in
different
Fields but perhaps the most famous and
significant of earlier bass admission
was a man who is known by the name zero
yob which means black bird and may have
referred to his skin tone his actual
name was abul hassan ali i banoffee and
was from modern-day iraq he also lived
and worked in the bustling capital
Baghdad and was the pupil of the
previously mentioned is Huckle mostly
during the reign of Harun al-rashid at
some point however he left the
Ambassador Court and traveled West some
say this was because a beef erupted
between him and his master is Huckle
mostly but others say it was because Al
Mamun deposed his brother al-amin as
Calif and he had to flee because of that
but I think the former option is a lot
more funny so we'll consider that cannon
in any case Arab eventually arrives in
Andaluz whereas modern Spain which was
ruled by the Umayyad dynasty in Spain
the ruler Abdul Rahman the second
appears to have been a great lover of
music as was his successors and so Syria
was able to establish himself as a very
respected musician in that region as
well the job was given a very warm
welcome into the court of musicians in
Spain including by a guy named Al
Mansour the Jew who was in fact Jewish
stories tell of how Syria revolutionized
the musical tradition in Cordoba and
almost single-handedly developed a
sophisticated culture of court music in
Spain well not this is chuh is hard to
say of course but it seems from most
sources that Syria was a very talented
musician who influenced the music
culture of al-andalus significantly
bringing with him influences from
Baghdad and opening a School of Music in
Cordoba this may have been the first or
at least one of the first schools of
music in all of Europe here he would
train students in music both singing and
playing instruments like the hood and
both men and women in fact women I'll be
mostly slave women played a very
important role in the music culture of
al-andalus in zero Ops time as well as
other parts of the Muslim world to these
women were often instrumental but pawn
absolutely intended in composition and
also in teaching music to others so with
the establishment of this School of
Music in Cordoba there now existed three
main centres of music in the so-called
Muslim world at time this is
ninth century one in cordoba one in
bhagavad and one in medina the city of
the prophets
Syria was a master of the oude the
Arabic lute and his that I've also added
a fifth string to the instruments but
the same invention is also attributed to
alkyne D and Al Farabi so who really
knows who did it in any case in the
following centuries they would develop a
very distinct Andalusia and North
African musical form which would differ
somewhat from the more Eastern Front of
music and Baghdad and other regions and
a lot of this kind of music is
attributed to as Arab and his influence
in Andalusia and Moroccan music such as
the traditional nubes sweet mawashi
Sajal and other genres we can hear clear
influences from both Arabic and Persian
music mixed with the local traditions of
the African Berber tribes and these
Spaniards it's hard to know what the
music back then actually sounded like as
no music was actually written down but
certain traditions do survive and can
sound something like this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
even though the lines between styles and
genres of music is of course very blurry
there was a very distinct form of music
that developed in Spain North Africa at
the time being a very multicultural
region as well as being a relatively
tolerant and open culture the music that
was developed during the Muslim rule
would greatly developed later European
classical and traditional music forms
which can still be heard today
especially in genres like flamenco a
somewhat coherent musical tradition had
thus developed in Muslim lands by the
9th century in Africa of course there
were regional differences and the
development of its very rich tradition
would only continue going forward in
history as I mentioned earlier music was
often a very important part of higher
education it was seen as a kind of
philosophy and connected to cosmological
religious and metaphysical ideas this
becomes especially apparent as the
individuals who would mostly carry
forward the musical tradition at least
theoretically is actually the
philosophers of the files of a tradition
in fact whereas music and its science
was transmitted primarily orally at this
time the first actual writings about
music in the Arabic or Muslim world in
general comes from the very famous 9th
century philosopher al Kindi
he's known as the first Arabic
philosopher him was a brilliant polymath
in the House of Wisdom in Baghdad he
translated Greek texts into Arabic and
were treatises on logic astronomy ethics
psychology and music among many more
several of his works were on music and
in which he develops a musical theory
that was partly based on the Greek
tradition in these writings he talks
about the wood the lute how it should be
tuned string length and so on he talks
about scales and octaves rhythms
compositional techniques the best way to
practice music and so on al Kindi is a
very significant figure not just in the
history of philosophy but also in the
development of music theory and Arabic
music generally to the philosophers
music was often subsumed under the
larger scientific category of
mathematics
believe it or not and was often treated
as such the rhythms and modes have very
rules that are connected to among other
things in the a platonic philosophical
ideas that were very popular at the time
his successors in the philosophical
tradition followed suit the philosopher
Al Farabi for example wrote a book
called kitab Alamosa and Kabir which
means the great book of music in which
he further develops the ideas that al
Kindi had had theorized this book is one
of the most significant works about
music generally in the medieval Muslim
world and I think in world history and
there is no actual translation of it
into English this is something that I
look forward to either someone else or
maybe myself during at some point in the
future this is a very important work
another a famous philosopher Eibon Sina
devoted a large portion of his book Al
Shifa the healing to music and even the
Awana Safa the brethren of purity
dedicated an entire epistle in their
great work or dedicated this to music
specifically so you can see that music
was a very prominent part of philosophy
as you can tell then many of these great
scholars and philosophers were often
musicians themselves which shows you
what an important position had had in
certain circles of society and confirms
my previous point that it was an
important part of higher education at
this time these philosophers and
musicians developed the Arabic music
theory that to some degree survives to
this day they talked about theories of
scales or what will become a mahkum
theory the musical modes in arabic music
and it kha or rhythms and how they are
connected in different kinds of genres
and styles of music there's a lot of
stuff in here quite telling of these
kinds of texts is the Epistle dedicated
to the science of music by the Iguana
sofa or the brethren of purity in which
they compare the arts of music to other
forms of Arts in a very I think
beautiful section quote you should know
there brother may God aid you and us
with a spirit of his that in every
manual craft the matter dealt with
consists of naturally occurring material
and that all of its products are
physical forms the exception is music
for the matter it deals with consists
entirely of spiritual substances namely
the so
of those who listen to it in other words
where as a painter works with a brush
and paint the sculptor works with stone
and the cook works with food for example
that which the musician works with and
shapes are the souls of other
individuals I just absolutely love this
description in this comparison they go
on to explain that music has many
different functions and effects on the
human being can inspire them to work
harder inspire them to fight in a battle
it can make them happy and sad
contemplative basically music has the
capability of affecting the souls of
human beings in a very strong way quote
it is clear from what we have expounded
that the art of music has differing
effects on the soul of listeners
parallel to the differing effects of the
arts of craftsmen on the material used
in their craft because of this all
nations of humankind make use of it as
too many animals also but above all to
the Elan and many of these philosophers
music actually has a divine origin to
these philosophers the beautiful sounds
we hear in music are actually like a
mirroring of the world of spirits these
beautiful sounds are a mirroring or a
taste of the divine world of harmony and
angels and all this so when we hear
music we are getting a glimpse of a
higher reality of paradise out of the
spiritual realm in the harmony of music
we are witnessing the harmony and beauty
of creation itself and some Sufis would
even say that we are getting a glimpse
of God himself but of course because of
this there was a lot of rules connected
to music as well since music was
connected to philosophical systems and
ideas the music needed to reflect this -
this is where these writers developed
musical theories that are connected to
your Platonic ideas about the spheres or
the humors and the body or the elements
in the world to demonstrate this we're
going to talk about a specific
instrument which is the food or the lute
the ode was seen as the most exalted of
instruments all of these great
philosophers and musicians basically
play in the old is hopper mostly played
at zero AB play the old
al-kindi played evil al-farabi even-even
Cena appears to have liked the wood
al-kindi refers to the old as the
instrument of philosophers and had been
seen our writes about the old in his
book Al Shifa quote if there's any
instrument more noble than this it is
quite unknown to the practitioners of a
music and the clan as safar has the
following to say quote the most perfect
instrument devised by the sages and the
best of their creations is the
instrument called the old lute they're
gonna go on to describe how this
instrument should be constructed the
sizes of the different parts the strings
the pegs and every minut little detail
most of these philosophers did the same
in their text as this was very important
you know not only from a practical
musical standpoint but also from a
philosophical one now the question
whether this instrument has four strings
or five strings or whatever it may seem
like a very trivial question it was
actually a very strong point of
contention at the time 0ab as I said is
credited with having added a fifth
string to the instrument and the
philosopher al Kindi is appears also to
have suggested the same idea but in the
writings of the Aquinas Safa they make
it very clear that the number of strings
on the wood has to be four or the whole
system is ruined this is because the
four strings represent the four elements
of fire air water and earth the highest
string called Zhi it resembles the
element of fire as well as that of heat
and fierceness the second string mothma
resembles air and it's softness the
third string called masla resembles
water and it's redness and cold and
lastly the lowest string called bum
resembles the element of Earth being
very heavy and thick here we have a very
strong connection obviously between
music theory and Aristotelian philosophy
as well as Neoplatonic philosophy to
some degree where certain notes and
strings are given characteristics and
placements within a larger cosmological
scheme and this is significant on a
practical level as well for those of you
who know your medieval medicine you know
that people thought that the body
consisted of four different humors that
had to be in harmony with each other and
when you were sick that meant that one
of the humors were
in out-of-balance and all this and so
not surprisingly of course the four
strings of the ode aside from being
connected to the different elements were
also connected to these bodily humors
and so the old and music generally was
used in a practical sense in a medical
sense as well so different melodies or
scales were used to solve different
physical or mental problems some of the
DS could fix a depression perhaps and
other melodies would help with an
infection and so on some of this may
sound pretty strange to you but keep in
mind that there are people and
scientists working even today studying
the way that music can affect our brains
and our our moods and our health
generally so there is clearly something
very interesting here and they had
realized this even back then in the
Middle Ages so this is much of the basis
of the musical theory that would develop
in the Arabic and Persian and Turkish
world the modal system known as mahkumat
are it's very much based on many of
these theories as you can tell music was
a very large subject and was like today
used in many different contexts there
was a vocal and instrumental court music
used as entertainment for the caliphs
and rulers it was party music at
weddings
there was music that was used for
medical and therapeutic purposes there
was military music used in battle to
rally the troops Caravan music chanted
by the camel drivers the camel people
religious poetry being recited and song
and of course the mystical ritual music
of the Sufis the Sufis and their
connection to music is incredibly
significant the earliest forms of Sufism
in Baghdad in the 9th and 10th centuries
appears to have used music as a ritual
this ritual became known as sama which
is usually translated as audition but it
really means listening and in this
ritual which has taken many different
forms historically music was used along
with poetry and sometimes even certain
movements or kinds of dance to induce a
kind of trance or ecstasy this was a
very prominent part of religious
practice and mystic
practices for the Sufis from early on
and up to this day now the connection of
Sufism to music is so significant and
strong that I will dedicate a whole
separate video to that subject and thus
I will not be talking that much about
Sufism in this video so look forward to
that separate video at some point in the
near future
needless to say music took on many
different forms and was part of many
different aspects of society now we
should of course mentioned the
controversies and different opinions
regarding music at this time and later
times that were held by different
scholars and so on
even if music was very common obviously
not everyone liked it or thought it was
appropriate there has over the course of
many centuries and since the early
period of the Islamic religion or the
Islamic civilization been a great debate
regarding the permissibility of
listening to or playing music we could
speculate and trace the origins of this
negative stance towards music to the
fact that in the early period and even
during the time of the Prophet Muhammad
and before music was often in the region
very strongly associated with beautiful
slave women playing at gatherings of
rich greedy rulers often accompanied by
things like drinking alcohol and so
people would have a very negative
association to music at least certain
forms of music we'll get to this soon
but because of this music became very
strongly associated with worldliness
drunkenness and sexual promiscuity the
early jurists and Muslim scholars also
of course realized that music had a very
strong effect on human beings and their
behavior and so they wanted to some of
them at least wanted to emphasize the
dangers of music because of its strong
effects on the human body which is of
course in contrast to many other Sufis
and other scholars who would emphasize
that aspect as one of the the more
positive aspects of music so it's very
interesting and debate than that sense I
often hear people still claiming that
Islam forbids music and sure there were
many scholars back then who would hold
very negative views towards music but
the situation was a lot more nuanced
than that indeed there were also many
scholars who were not opposed to muse
as we have seen in our discussions so
far the Sufis have used music throughout
history as a religious practice to reach
ecstasy an intimacy with God often as I
said called sama or audition and thus
made music an important part of religion
for every scholar that viewed music as
prohibited there were scholars like eben
Cena eben rush or the Andalusia
naturalist even has amore Anika's Olli
abdullah al nabi Lucy or Abdul Rahman
Yami who all argued in a more nuanced
way that music in itself isn't
necessarily harmful people back then
weren't as rigid as people like to think
and it was never a black or white kind
of situation there is a whole spectrum
of opinions and stances on the subject
from sufi thinkers as well as non Sufi
scholars some viewing all music as
prohibited and wrong others view only
vocal music as being okay others think
that certain instruments like drums and
flutes are okay but not string
instruments for example others even
allowed all instruments but only certain
lyrics and others basically mute any
music as fine it literally is a whole
spectrum of opinions the very famous
Sufi scholar abu hamid al-ghazali who
was in favour of music albeit limiting
the instruments allowed once famously
wrote quote whoever says that all music
is prohibited let him also claim that
the songs of birds are prohibited
regardless of your opinion that's a
great quote discussions were not only
had about certain instruments but also
different kinds of music as well this is
a very important point that a lot of
people especially today forget that we
say music that contains all kinds of
music but back then different terms was
used to denote different kinds of what
we would call music today and the
opinions on these different kinds of
music could differ dramatically there's
a great graph in an article by lewis
absent al farabi that gives a
generalizing look at the traditional
attitudes towards different forms of
music as you can see here there are
certain genres that were almost always
considered halal or permitted including
things like religious chants
wedding music and military music work
songs and so on
then we have a category in which the
opinions may differ or be more
ambivalent some consider them permitted
others would be more skeptical or
hostile this includes composed art music
both vocal and instrumental and music
with pre-islamic origins the only
category that most scholars have always
agreed to be prohibited or forbidden is
music with a strong sexual or a sensual
content or performed in certain contexts
that are somehow unacceptable
perhaps music being performed in
relation to drinking alcohol for example
as you can see we now have a much more
nuanced and less problematic picture of
the situation the scholar Amnon shaloha
writes quote in some the attitudes
towards music has always been ambivalent
as expressed in a series of
contradictory feelings and concepts
predilection and mistrust divine
devilish exalting disruptive admissible
prohibited this complexity and nuance
should be kept in mind as we go forward
there have been scholars and jurists on
both sides of the arguments and then the
case music continued to develop in the
Abbasid in the Umayyad and in the
Fatimid and all of these different
dynasties that would appear music
continued to flourish and be developed
in different ways if music theory
started with the philosopher al Kindi
and then further developed over the
centuries it can be said to have
culminated in a way around the time of
the fall of the Abbasid Caliphate and
with a man by the name of Sofia Dean al
Otto Maui
he lived in Baghdad during the reign of
caliphs al most unsaid and alma Stassen
and would first handedly witnessed the
invasion of the Mongol army the sacking
of the historical great city of Baghdad
and the execution of the last ambassador
caleb being a very talented musician as
well as a calligrapher he was kept alive
and continued to serve under the later
Mongol rulers in the city as well
but before this very historical event he
had already written a book called the
katana doir the book of cycles or modes
basically which would cement him as one
of the most important and significant
music theorists in history
indeed the musicologist or one right
says that quote there can be little
doubt that the most influential of all
Arabic treatises on music has been the
key tablet wha what my way was perhaps
unsurprisingly an ood player and he
brought texts about the old but it was
in his system at the session of music
theory that he left his greatest mark in
the history of music he follows in the
tradition of the previous philosophers
but systematizes the Arabic music theory
in a way that has left its mark to this
very day in the kitab an ad while he
talks about tetra courts Penta chords
and how they are played on various
instruments he also very importantly
divides the octave into 17 intervals and
then starts to forms modes out of these
intervals this then becomes the very
first systematized version and
classification of maqams in arabic music
in a way that the modal system that is
still in use in Arabic and Turkish music
today he mentions the names of a few of
these modes and maqams most of which are
still in use shaloha again comments
quote an eminent theorist as well as
musician he achieved a systematization
of the general scale and the whole model
system that was probably impractical
used long before his time I have some
bad news because unfortunately with all
of the musicians and great theorists
that we have been talking about none of
this music actually survives today
because music back then was never
written down there was no notation
everything was transmitted orally but
this is actually one of the other very
significant things about Safford in an
Audemars we because in his writings we
find the as far as we know earliest
example of actual musical notation it is
very rudimentary notation and it isn't
really songs per se it's actually more
of a kind of exercise he's notating an
exercise for playing the wood and for
singing but nonetheless this would pave
the way for later Ottoman writers who
would actually create a system of music
notation for the
Eastern world well these notations are
very hard to play and as I said amount
to no more than simple exercises and and
very short melodies that have been
attempt to actually recreate and record
some of these melodies albeit with a
very heavy dose of interpretation and
improvisation for example here is a
recording by the musician Devon rod who
tries to interpret some of these error
notations on Maui and his key table
advil is referred to when referenced
four years afterwards in all regions
from India to Spain the tradition that
was started by al Kindi can be said in a
way to culminate with an umami in this
sense but that is not to say that music
did not continue to develop afterwards
instead we could see as a kind of
turning point are very important central
point for the development of music
theory when talking about the great
philosopher eben Cena once sometimes
divides exam Muslim philosophy into pre
even Xena and after even Xena of course
it didn't end with a benzina
but it's a very important turning point
I think the same kind of view can be
used about autumn aware that there's a
priori Maui music and a post-war Maori
music in the next part of the series
which I'm planning we will talk about
the post a Bassett era of Islamic music
everything from the composer of the Lada
Alma dolly to Amir Khusro in India to
the Ottoman music and the music of the
nobility order which I very strongly
connected I hope this video didn't feel
too long but it's a very broad and
complex subject that I wanted to do
justice and so a longer video was kind
of required nonetheless I hope you enjoy
this video if you want to continue this
discussion in the comments that would be
highly encouraged and you want to
support this channel you can either
support me on patreon I will leave a
link to my pitch on page in the
description but you can also simply like
the video and subscribe to this channel
and I will see you next time
[Music]